[Music]
Welcome back to our next episode of
What's Up Prof.
Hello Walter.
We say hello Walter all the time. So
I'll say hello Martin.
Thank you.
Um we're going to have a interesting
discussion today and we need the
guidance of the Holy Spirit. So I'll
pray for us.
Our heavenly father,
Lord, there's so much deception in the
world and there's so many voices out
there. Help us to discern these things.
Help us in our discussion. And we ask
this in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen.
So, we're going to talk about miracles,
wonders, signs, all of these things.
Well, we've touched on it on many
occasions. Matthew 24 and all of these.
But just to bring it up to our time,
let's have a look at some of these
things. Now, there are physical signs
and then there are spiritual signs. Our
emphasis today is spiritual signs
and uh we're going to talk about
prophets and miracles and wonders and
where God's people should take note.
Yes.
Be careful. Tread softly because we have
serious warnings in the Bible about
these things. But before they we go
there, let's look at some of the
physical things that are happening.
Trump issues presidential disaster
declaration for California. We just put
this in to show there are major things
happening now. There've always been
fires in California, but these are
somehow different from the previous
ones. Yeah,
there's quite some eerie
eerie things going on
going on with it.
Yes. And thank you to the president for
your partnership and granting this
urgent major disaster declaration.
California is battling two of the
largest fires in our history and has
seen nearly 600 new fires in the last
week caused by dry lightning strikes.
So, new lightning ex is expected and
these dry lightning strikes that means
there's no precipitation. Some people
say there was no thunder which was
strange and and there have been reports
of that in other places in Ireland. The
BBC reported
that a few years ago there were
lightning storms without thunder and
they're talking about bent atmosphere
and this and that and the other.
But it's just interesting that the
disasters are escalating and as you see
this is escalation
such as we have not previously seen.
Sandra is saying that they show the
lightning strikes and they talk about
between 10 and 12,000 lightning strikes
causing all of these fires. So that's
incredible, isn't it?
Let's just look at this little video and
see what they say.
So, we had all of those strikes and
every time there's a red flare, there's
a fire and the clouds are gone. And of
course, there are many conspiracy
theories about what caused them, etc.
But uh be that as it may, the Bible
tells us that there will be physical
signs. And the spirit of prophecy tells
us that these physical manifestations
and the disasters will bring people to
the point where they say we have to get
back to God. We have to start
implementing
legislation
etc etc. But today we want to
concentrate on the spiritual aspects.
In 2 Thessalonians chapter 2 verse9 we
read,
"Even him whose coming is after the
working of Satan with all powers and
signs and lying wonders."
In Mark 13:22, it says, "For false
Christs and false prophets shall arise
and shall show signs and wonders to
seduce, if it were possible, even the
elect."
And Jesus warned in John 4:48,
"Then said Jesus unto him, except ye see
signs and wonders, you will not
believe."
So it's amazing that part of the human
psych seems to require signs and work.
Yeah. That's why Jesus said you want the
signs.
So somebody will supply the signs so
that you may believe the falsehood.
The only safety we have in this world
today is the word of God.
So we will have false messiahs. We will
have false prophets. We will have false
Christs. We will have signs and wonders.
We've been warned that these things will
come.
Here's the a quote from the book
Maranata, the corruption of truth. Then
if any man shall say unto you, lo, here
is Christ or there believe it not.
Why should we not believe it? Because
the Bible is very clear that when Jesus
returns for the second time, he will not
be on this earth. We will meet him in
the sky. So anything that happens here
in the desert or in the inner room is
not from God.
As we near the end of time, falsehood
will be so mingled with truth that only
those who have the guidance of the Holy
Spirit will be able to distinguish truth
from error. Let's just stop there.
The Bible is very clear also in the book
of Acts where it says and God gives the
Holy Spirit to them that obey him. So
obedience
and the true spirit go hand in hand.
We need to make every effort to keep the
way of the Lord. We must in no case turn
from his guidance to put our trust in
man. The Lord's angels are appointed to
keep strict watch over those who put
their faith in the Lord. And these
angels are to be our special help in
every time of need. Every day we are to
come to the Lord with full assurance of
faith and to look to him for wisdom.
Those who are guided by the word of the
Lord will discern with certainty between
falsehood and truth, between sin and
righteousness.
That's a very important criterion.
In fact, that was the foundation for the
reformation.
Yes.
The word.
The problem is a lot of people use the
word
and giving false prophecies as well.
That's true. So, it has to be in harmony
with the word and not out of context.
That's
false miracles. Are God's people
prepared for false miracles? It is fully
time that every responsible worker
should take his stand firmly on the word
of God.
This word is to be our defense when
Satan works with such lying wonders that
if it were possible, he would deceive
the very elect.
It is then that those who have not stood
firmly for the truth will unite with the
unbelieving who love and make a lie.
When these wonders are performed, when
sick are healed and other marvels are
wrought, they will be deceived. Are we
prepared for the perilous times that are
right upon us? Or are we standing where
we will fall an easy prey to the ws of
the devil? I find it interesting that
she says here that unbelievers will
unite
yes
with believers who are being deceived
and they will make a union.
That's very interesting.
That's very interesting. But again, you
have to stand firmly upon the word of
God. That is a the Protestant principle
solar script. If it doesn't say so, it
is not so. Even if it looks like it
should be so, but it is not so because
it does not say so.
Simple, right?
Simple.
All right. So Jesus Christ appears
shining like a bright light and he's
talking to a group of people somewhere
and you know that's not him
because he's not going to come like
that.
Correct. He's going to come that every
eye can see him.
There will be miracle working power of
Satan and he will deceive many. As the
condition of the church and the world
was opened before me and I beheld the
fearful scenes that lay just before us,
I was alarmed at the outlook. And night
after night, while all in the house were
sleeping, I wrote out the things given
me of God. I was shown the heresies
which are to arise, the delusions that
will prevail, the miracle working power
of Satan, the false Christs that will
appear, that will deceive the greater
part even of the religious world, and
that would, if it were possible, draw
away even the elect.
We are heading for some serious trouble.
Yes. And you know in the last few years
how many winds of doctrine have been
blowing even within our own church.
Yeah. All of a sudden it's like the slle
has been opened and all of a sudden the
pillars no longer were pillars
but were based on falsehood.
Amazing.
Many will go from us. That's a rather
sad statement, giving heed to seducing
spirits. A superficial faith results in
a superficial experience.
The light given me has been very
forcible that many would go out from us,
giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of devils. The Lord desires
that every soul who claims to believe
the truth shall have an intelligent
knowledge of what is truth. Let me just
stop there.
In other words,
what the church has believed since its
inception
all of a sudden will be questioned here
at the end.
And a groups or groups of people will
arise that will suddenly say that
everything we believed up until now
is based on a falsehood
from within. from within.
So anything new that starts coming in
like a rushing torrent, we should be
very weary and ask ourselves,
did the reformers believe that? Did the
pioneers of this church believe that
when the foundations were laid upon
which this house is built? Mhm.
Was that foundation sound or was it a
false foundation?
Have we been building on sand ever since
that time?
Yeah.
Now, just ask yourselves that question.
I'm not even mentioning
the doctrines that are coming in.
I'm not mentioning them by name. Let
everybody out there consider
what in the last few years has been
coming in like a flood
in a form of a wind of doctrine where
people are saying if you don't believe
this you're part of Babylon and they're
out.
Yeah.
There's no coming out no
out of the lost remnant movement.
There's only a spitting out.
A shaking.
There's a shaking.
Yeah. The shaking is shaking you out. So
let everybody just consider that and
think for themselves. What has been made
prominent in the last few years
and why wasn't it prominent beforehand?
False prophets will arise and they will
deceive many. Everything is to be shaken
that can be shaken. Then does it not
become everyone to understand the
reasons of our faith?
In place of having so many sermons,
there should be a more close searching
of the word of God, opening the
scripture text by text and searching for
the strong evidence that sustains the
fundamental doctrines that have brought
us where we are now, upon the platform
of eternal truth. So that's our
foundation.
Yes.
Uh I'm going to mention one.
When you start touching the deity of
Christ,
then the warning bells should ring with
a resounding ring. The shutters should
come down and a bullwalk must be erected
against whatever is attacking the deity
of Christ. In the beginning was the word
and the word was with God and the word
was God. By him were all things created
and without him was not anything
created. Before Abraham was I am.
Thomas fell at his feet and said my Lord
and my God. The healed people fell at
his feet and worshiped him and he
accepted the worship which no angel even
does. How much evidence do you need?
Yes.
And then you have the spirit of
prophecy. In him was life unborrowed,
unerrived.
He said, "I take up my life. I lay it
down. Nobody takes with from me. I have
power to lay it down. I will take it up
again."
How much evidence do you want?
Right. And yet this is happening
everywhere.
Everywhere.
And Martin Luther said, "The God who
didn't die for me is not my God."
The first little wind that blows in that
direction.
Barricade yourself because it's going to
turn into a tornado. Correct. It's a
fullness of God. It's not a lesser God
or
Yes. He did not consider it robbery to
be equal with God. I mean, I could go on
forever. I'm very passionate about that.
Don't touch the deity of Christ.
Amen.
Okay, I've got that out of my system.
We've had this before, but uh it's
interesting how it is progressing. This
one is now from August 2020.
Israeli rabbi says he's already holding
meetings with the Messiah. This is a
very secretive Messiah. I thought he was
coming like lightning that one would see
him from the east of the west every eye
will see him. But he's having a secret
meeting.
Secret meeting. Yeah.
Can you believe this? No,
you're not going to believe this. You're
not going to believe this. It's
interesting that, you know,
uh, the Jewish nation is waiting for the
Messiah, but they're waiting for a
national deliverer, right?
The same that they did 2,000 years ago.
Exactly. The exactly the same mistake.
And we want to be delivered from this
virus that is called sin.
People are worried about Corona virus.
They should be worried about the virus
called sin.
Definitely. So here they are having
secret meetings and again he belongs
this rabbi who is very respected rabbi
scold says that Kypski and others of the
mystical concealed rabbis.
Now this is very interesting because
they also believe of course that in any
time period in history there must be 36
righteous people on earth. Okay,
36 of them
and they don't even know that they are
the righteous ones. But because of them,
God spares the entire world because of
these 36 righteous people. And they will
be from the Jewish community and
probably
maybe one of these rabbis, but uh they
won't themselves even know that they
belong to these righteous ones.
Now the number 36 is interesting
because that deals with the
constellations of the stars. It's
actually a spiritualistic cabalistic
view.
Okay.
36 rooms in the zodiac and uh you know
each room of course must be occupied. So
this is spiritualism mingled with
religion.
So he began his explosive three-hour
interview with a warning. The process of
redemption is about to start happening
very quickly and at a fast pace. It is
important that people remain calm and
steady to act properly in the right
time. Now the redemption they're talking
about is not redemption from sin.
This is redemption from circumstance.
Right.
Mhm.
getting the word out now that the
Messiah is closer than ever is a matter
of life and death. Haven't you heard of
Gog and Mog?
So, it's interesting that you know the
Russians are in that and
it it is such a confusion. What we're
trying to say here is that the Christian
world has been drawn into this
philosophy of the Jewish Messiah who
will come which is a misnomer in itself
because Christian world believes in the
Messiah who has already come.
Yes.
And it will come with power and great
glory.
Correct.
How can you actually accommodate
two versions of the Messiah?
Yeah, that's actually very interesting
you you mentioned that because
now come to think of it, it is um almost
impossible.
Yes,
you've got the first Messiah
that the Christians believe in that came
and he's coming the second time. And
like you said, now the Jews expect their
Messiah to come for the first time.
Yes.
And he's coming to But I think the
Now if you get them confused and you
make them the same person in your mind,
then they also believe that the church
is being raptured, which is a Jesuit
theology being taken away while the
Messiah is down here probably for a
thousand years. So what are they going
to be? Widows up there.
So that's where the confusion comes in.
It's it's totally unbiblical.
Yes. Because now also these Christians
are waiting and the Jews are waiting for
this Messiah to come and rule on earth
for a thousand years.
What does it mean when the Bible says
your house has been left to you
desolate?
It means there's nothing there. Now this
house is the nation, not the people.
Because Paul makes it very clear that
they have been cut out of the vine.
But because they were natural branches,
they can easily be grafted back in. But
what was the condition for being grafted
back in
obedience?
You have to accept the Jesus Christ as
the Messiah. Then you are grafted back
in
because he's the vine.
He is the vine. So if you do not accept
this, now they say the messianic Jews
are accepting Jesus Christ as the
Messiah.
But again there is this difference that
their Jesus is a national deliverer.
It's still the nation that is prominent
and the nation will rule over the other
nations eventually. That is the
philosophy.
But Jesus came to deliver us from sin.
His kingdom is not of this world.
And there's a millennium where it says
that the saints will be given or the the
judgment will be handed over to the
saints.
So after that millennium, they return to
this earth. The holy city comes down.
The unrighteous are resurrected
and they are judged. Fire comes down
from heaven and devours them. There's no
eternal hell that burns. The results of
the fire are eternal. They will be ashes
under their feet. The Bible is very
clear. They will be as though they never
were.
So this is such a confusion. This is a
Jesuit doctrine that has come into the
world. The Bible has one Messiah and
that is Jesus Christ, the God man. Mhm.
That's why you have to touch the
divinity of Christ. You have to get rid
of it if you want to mingle all of this
stuff together
cuz you have to even fit in the Iman Mi
which is the Islamic Messiah.
You have to fit him in and and you want
them all to to coexist.
Yeah.
And then you have the Hindu Krishna. How
you going to accommodate them all?
There's one name under heaven and earth
whereby you can be saved and that is
untouchable.
And taking away the divinity of Christ,
you can
you can do that.
You can do that.
You can do anything.
Top rabbi ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra rabbis look
for signs the messiah is coming. So what
are the signs that they're looking for?
Israel is about to go to the polls for
the third election. So this is a couple
of months ago and they're talking about
Rabbi Amar, the former Sephardic chief
rabbi told the gathering earlier this
month that the list of significant signs
of the past year simply cannot be
ignored. Israel seems unable to elect a
government. That's a sign.
How many countries are unable to elect
the government? They're all fighting. US
President Trump the most powerful leader
in the world has like King Cyrus
endorsed Jewish sovereignty in the
promised land. So that is linking the
Christian world with the Jewish world.
The kings of this world came up to
Jerusalem. That's when all the
dignitaries came for the Holocaust
remembrance in Jerusalem. These things
were never dreamed of explained Rabba
Amma. How can these things be if not as
preparation for the coming of the
Messiah?
So, we've also got that peace agreement
that probably is also a sign.
Everything is a sign. Everything becomes
a sign. Now, where does it say in the
Bible that Prince when Prince Charles
comes to visit
South Africa or New Zealand, that's a
sign that the Messiah is coming. Just
say that anywhere.
So, where does this come from? Not from
the Bible.
No.
So the Messiah is at the door. So he
talks about all of these issues and
according to Amar's former spiritual
advisor was just about to leave for a
trip abroad recently when Rabbi Kifski
stopped him saying you are going abroad.
You don't know that the Messiah is
standing at the door.
So what are the signs? All the great
rabbis of just generation are saying
that the Messiah is about to reveal
himself. That's important. All the signs
of the prophets gave are all the signs
predicted in the gimar, the Mishna, the
midrash, everything is taking place one
by one. All we need is to remain strong
for a little bit longer.
Where's the Bible?
He then urged Jews everywhere to commit
themselves to Torah observance, in
particular, keeping the Shabbat. That's
interesting.
Orthodox Judaism has long taught that
the Messiah will only come once all the
Jews are sanctifying the Shabbat.
Do you find that interesting?
Very interesting. So, how
how's this linking up with the Sunday?
Doesn't it strike you that in recent
times, Israel has actually opened up
their stores and their their transport
and their conveniences on the Sabbath
day
and have introduced a parallel Sunday
observance.
Yeah,
I find that fascinating.
So, might there even be an acceptance of
a universal
Shabbat?
It is notable how closely Rabbi Amar's
exhortation echoes that of Yeshua,
Jesus.
Stay dressed for action and keep your
lamps burning and be like men who are
waiting for their master to come home
from the wedding feast so that they may
open the door to him at once when he
comes and knocks. You must also be ready
for the Son of Man is coming at an hour
you do not expect.
Interesting. Yes. So they even quote the
New Testament.
Start praying. Just after Rabbi Amar
made these stunning remarks, Rabbi
Afnner Fim expressed a similar view in
an interview with a religious Israeli
news portal. Kikar
Hashabat.
He's one of the world's top cabalist
rabbis.
That's mysticism.
That's mysticism. Now, doesn't the Bible
warn against mysticism?
Yes.
So, we have all this mingling of
spiritualism. Now, the Bible clearly
says that the end time Babylon
is a triune union. Yes. Of the beast,
the dragon, and the false prophet. and
spiritualism forms a very important
component
of this mix.
And he likewise believes that what has
happened here over the past year is most
definitely a sign of the coming of
Messiah. It would be advisable to study
the Torah
and pray.
Good morning, Israel. Jerusalem welcomes
the kings of the Gentiles.
So convoy of airplanes arrive and all of
these kings came to visit.
King Phillip of Spain, King Villim
Alexander of Holland, King Phillip of
Belgium, Prince Charles and heir to the
throne of Norway, Prince Hon Magnus.
Other guests included the French
president Emanuel Macron, German
president Frank Washstein Maya, the
presidents of Italy, Bulgaria,
etc. Vladimir Putin. These are signs
that the Messiah is coming.
So you can make anything a sign, right?
We need to stick to the Bible.
The state of Israel, the restoration of
Israel. When the Bible talks about
Israel at the end of time, Israel means
he who wrestled with God
and overcame
and the name of Jacob was changed to
Israel. And then the Bible is very clear
that if you are in Christ, then you are
the Israel of God.
Amen. So we've gone from a literal
typological
Israel to a spiritual Israel. So anybody
who accepts Jesus Christ as the savior
from your sinful condition,
he is the one that belongs to the Israel
of God. So this Israel is not in the
Bible as a physical entity because when
it says your house will be left you
desolate that's what it means as a
political entity
individually except Christ and you can
be grafted in.
Amen.
Now when it comes to these prophets in
the western world now then it becomes
very fascinating and we have to be very
careful to make sure
that we are walking on biblical ground.
Now, when it comes to the Western world
and we're looking at some of the
prophets of this age, the people that
get visions from God,
we have a very interesting video here
where Sid Roth, who has a YouTube
channel which is called It's
Supernatural,
and he's talking to a pastor, Jeff
Jansen, who wrote a book, The Destiny of
God's America,
and he's talking about Donald Trump and
the probability of or the definite
victory of Donald Trump. And he refers
back to a vision or an encounter that
what George Washington had. Now, what's
interesting is that this vision is uh
prophetic about the United States of
America and how long it will exist,
etc., etc.
And we have to put that into a context
with the Bible. Now let me just talk a
little bit about George Washington. We
know that he was a Freemason.
He was a very high Freemason.
And there are many many pictures of him
with his apron and the inaugurations
etc. And one wonders whether these
visions were necessarily visions from
God. Right?
But the whole world is excited about
this. Now, the Sidroth is a Messianic
Jew or is a a Jew that has accepted uh
Yeshua as he says and it just sets the
stage because this is the hype in the
religious world today and we need to
discuss this because even the elect will
have to determine is something from God
or is something not from God. Right? So
let's have a look at this interview and
then we'll stop it occasionally because
there are some very interesting things
which are being said in the natural I
don't think Trump really stands a chance
if you believe in polls but I believe in
God and I believe God is going to trump
the polls.
God is going to trump the polls and it
it would be scary if if Biden would get
in but he is not going to. I've seen
very clearly. I saw the first
presidential election and I was one of
the few voices out there saying
President Trump will be elected. Stand
back. Watch what happens. God's going to
turn the tide. He is going to get in in
this second uh the second election. And
uh this is part of the prophecy that is
written in this book, the brand new
book. Um you know um uh Trump the the
destiny of God's America. It talks about
the the vision uh that President George
Washington had back in 1777. And when
the angel visited him, Trump uh uh the
angel visited uh uh George Washington in
the in the tent said he saw uh three
major perils that would come to America.
And the angel led him through each
peril. The first peril was about the
Revolutionary War. The second peril was
about the Civil War. And he saw how how
each time the country came together back
into unity through these perils. But
there was another peril that came and
the angel said this is the most
dangerous peril. And we have not to date
seen that peril. But I believe this is
what George Washington saw back in 1777.
And what he saw was this dark clouds
that came from around different nations
from all around the world. And it was
not a physical army. it. He described it
as a black cloud that had red eyes or
red flashes in it. And uh and it was a
demonic army, a demonic presence. And he
saw buildings burning. I mean, look
what's happening in our country now. He
saw buildings burning. He saw all kinds
of people fighting and millions of
voices crying out. And he said that he
watched this like a television screen.
that I've been in involved in, you know,
I' I've been in encounters like that,
prophetic encounters, and like this
prophet that you're talking about. He
saw things. I've seen things like this.
Well, President George Washington saw
these things as well. And he said right
when it looked like uh all hope would be
lost. He said that the angel that was
there in the vision took a trump and he
put it to his mouth and he blew a he
blew a long fearful blast. And that's
what the angels
did. He excuse me. Did he use the word
in the vision? Did President George
Washington use the word Trump in his
vision?
It was trumpet, but it was also Trump.
There's one place where it says Trump
and then it says Trumpet. So you can say
Trumpet or Trump. I think it's pretty
clear what that is. You know,
irregardless when this chaos was
happening in America, the angel put a
trumpet or a trump to his mouth and
released a long fearful blast. And it
says that the light of a thousand sons
invaded. This is the this is the God
factor, Sid, that you were seeing. The
God factor is that at the sound of that
trump, which I believe is the glory of
God, the restoration of this nation that
will carry us into the future, only God
can do this. That trumpet sound came and
the light of a thousand sons invaded
America and pushed back the dark clouds
and again
life came back into America and people
had hope again. And the angel that was
in that vision took the crown that said
union on his head and he placed it on
the people and the people bowed down and
said amen. And then the angel said one
more thing. He said, "As long as there
are stars in the heaven, and as long as
the dew comes down upon the earth, so
shall the union live forever."
Now, let's just stop it right there for
a moment.
What we seeing here is an a recounting
of the vision of George Washington, who,
as we said, was a Freemason.
Yes. Now, if you read Albert Pike's
book, then it is pretty clear who the
god of Freemasonry is.
And it's definitely not the God of the
Bible. Right.
Correct.
Because he literally says that it is
Lucifer.
Now the other interesting thing is he
talks about these thousand lights
and George Bush senior also used that
when he spoke about the new world order
where he spoke about the thousand points
of light
and that is a it's a luciferian doctrine
and we have to ask ourselves
will God
use someone that is in a secret society
that has a Luciferian
origin,
will he use someone like that to reveal
the future of God's kingdom to him? Does
he fulfill the criteria
of the Bible
of what a prophet should be like? A
prophet must have an exemplary life. A
prophet must be obedience obedient to
God's precepts.
Yes.
A prophet must have fruits in harmony
with the biblical criteria. And there
are all the other signs. We're not going
to deal with the signs of a prophet.
We've done that before. But that has a
basis.
And then to take certain words out of a
prophecy like he used the Trump and to
apply that to Donald Trump
is stretching it somewhat, wouldn't you
say?
Yes, definitely.
So, let's continue with this. Uh,
it's like you mentioned those day back
in a previous episode that we did of
Nostradamus.
It's so so broadly they fit everything
into it eventually. Eventually
everything fits in. Now this particular
video is is interesting and this book is
very prominent in the United States at
the moment but uh many many prophets
align themselves. There are differences
and they have different aspects but this
is basically the core of what the
evangelical world is running with at the
moment.
Yes. Correct. different prophets.
Everybody eventually comes to this same
exactly
point
to the law
and to the testimony. If they speak not
according to this word, there is no
light in them. The Holy Spirit is given
to them that obey him. Now, I'm not
saying that God doesn't lead people.
God certainly leads people even people
that have never heard of the truth to
the truth through his spirit. So this
leading of the spirit applies to
everyone.
But to be a prophet takes very specific
criteria. And I am fearful for the world
that they put faith in people that do
not necessarily qualify in terms of the
criteria.
If we hold back like what happened in
1973 with Row versus Wade and the
leaders, they didn't want to get
involved because there's a separation
between church and state. That is the
most ridiculous demonic mindset. We need
to lift our voices to to to have our
voices counted in the courts of heaven
to be able to release the verdict that
God wants. God is looking for someone to
agree with him on the planet. And that's
the church. The church has the final
say. We might be the least according to
them, according to the media, the fake
news, but we have the final say. If my
people that are called by my name shall
humble themselves, we will shift the
tide. God is looking for his people to
get involved and to shift the tide.
Let's just stop right there and then
we'll continue with this video.
What did he say? The church and state
separation was
demonic.
It was demonic.
Now, who also said that?
The Pope.
The Pope. Yes. He actually has many many
things to say about the separation of
church and state. Now when we look at
the various models in the world and this
is very important that our our listeners
understand this
we're dealing always when we're dealing
with the mindset of humanity and we're
not talking about small group here and a
small group there. We're talking about
all of humanity.
How do you shift this juggernaut, this
massive ship's mindset into the
direction that you want it to go?
Hegelian dialectic.
Right? So you have thesis, you have
anti-thesis, and you have synthesis.
Now, what is the papal
injunction? What does the papacy stand
for? The papacy always stood for the two
swords. the sword of the spirit
and the secular sword. And the papacy
has made it absolutely clear in
encyclical after encyclical that the
sword of the spirit is superior to the
secular sword and that the secular sword
is subject to the sword of the spirit.
So the church yields the divine sword
and the other one yields the secular
sword and the one is subordinate to the
other.
Now that is how the Roman Catholic
Church ruled the world in the middle
ages.
So those 10 horns
that ruled in the European countries and
all the countries that emanated from
them that are basically part of that
system had at one stage in the world's
history
given their power unto the beast power
the papal power
and they ruled and used the state to
enforce their dogmas.
And that's how it worked. But when the
papacy ruled, it had still separated the
church from the state.
The church held preeminence. But the
state had a measure of independence in
terms of ruling the nation. Only when it
came to the religious aspect did the
church dictate to the state.
Now that is one model.
Now when the French Revolution came that
model was dissolved
and you had the total separation of
church and state and so the secular
world
eliminated the church out of government.
And since the French Revolution, that
has been the model that has been
particularly followed in the United
States of America. And it's now come to
a point where morality has been thrown
out of the window. So there's a
clamoring to get back to this state. Now
this state that the papacy had was a
middle ground.
What is the other extreme? Because you
have a thesis, you have an anti-thesis,
right? The other extreme is where the
church rules absolutely.
Yes.
So the church becomes the state. That's
never the papal model.
And you have that in the Islamic world.
There for example, if you go to Iran,
the church is the state and the highest
leader is the ayatah who rules with
absolute authority over not only the
church
but over the country
but over the country over the state as
well. So that is the anti-thesis
and then you have the thesis. Let's
separate them completely which has been
since the state of the French revolution
which is not the ideal according to
Catholicism. They have the middle
ground. So now you have a thesis no god
in government. You have an anti-thesis.
The church rules absolutely. And both of
these are in absolute turmoil.
Yeah.
Absolute chaos. War, riots,
pain,
death, suffering. What's the solution?
The synthesis.
Yes. The Roman Catholic version.
And that's the Roman Catholic version.
You get back to square one, right? We go
back to the Middle Ages. That's where
we're heading.
Yep.
And this is what the man said. He echoes
Rome by saying that church and state
separation is demonic. They have to come
together.
They're the ones that will determine and
this is where they're heading. And
that's why Donald Trump is their
champion.
Yeah.
Now, we are not saying here at this
forum who's going to win. That's not our
place.
All we know is that the Bible says that
the king of the north philosophy in the
end will overcome the king of the south
philosophy and the king of the south
philosophy emanated from the French
Revolution. Yes.
So that's what you have in the United
States currently. And the Biden camp
obviously supports that more strongly
than the other one. Right.
Okay. So we have this scenario and then
you have the counterpole which is
absolute religious control.
One more thing that he said was that
this
America
and this union that he's talking about
this church and state ruling is going to
last for how long did he say?
Forever.
Now whose philosophy is that? Is that a
biblical philosophy?
No.
When you look at Daniel chapter 2,
what happens when the stone that's not
cut out by human hands? In other words,
this divine intervention strikes the
statue. What happens?
Makes it dust.
Dust. And even the dust will be swept
away. Right? There will remain nothing
of the earthly systems.
Now, whose philosophy are they actually
echoing now when they say that when the
church finally rules again,
it will be like the kingdom of God that
will rule forever. Whose philosophy is
that?
The Roman Catholic.
That is the Roman Catholic philosophy.
Roman Catholicism believes in a
millennialism.
Oh yes.
Amillennianism. In other words, there is
no millennium. When the church rules,
the kingdom will be here. So, the
kingdom is the kingdom on earth.
Mhm.
But Jesus said, "My kingdom is not of
this world."
And he's going to take his children away
at the last trump. The dead in Christ
will rise first. Those that are on the
world in the earth on the earth at that
stage will be translated in a moment in
the twinkling of an eye and together
with them they will meet the Lord in the
air.
And then they will be taken away to
heaven and there they will rule with God
a thousand years
in heaven. in heaven and the judgment
will be handed to them and the earth
will be obliterated. All the earthly
kingdoms will come to an end. This is
not biblical
no
prophecy.
Isn't it interesting? The same
philosophy is also with the other um
savior like um things we've been talking
about like youon and all this.
Everything is a kingdom on earth.
They're all waiting for the kingdom to
come and the kingdom will not be on
earth.
This earth is not going to become
better.
No. And they also have what we call a
second chance doctrine.
And there's no such thing. That would
not be fair towards all the previous
generations that don't have a second
chance doctrine. Right.
Correct. So I'm not doubting
I don't think we are doubting the
sincerity
of the people but what we are pointing
out is that if you are not rooted in the
word of God if you start playing
the game of incorporating everybody's
ideas whether he's a mason or whether he
is a whatever and saying that that
vision is what's going to unfold. old on
earth and applying it to our time,
you are not working with the word of
God.
It's not the right criterion. So, let's
continue and see what else he has to
say.
But I'll tell you here, um, it's not
just going to be this administration.
It's not just going to be the next four
years or eight years. I saw 20 years,
Sid. Clearly, I saw 20 years. And I
believe it's even further because the
Lord spoke to me and I saw in an
encounter. He said, "Jeff, when the last
trump sounds."
And I said, "What do you mean the last
trump sounds?" He said, "At the last
trump, it will sound." Well, the last
trump. And I said, "Lord, what do you
mean the last trump?" It was a play on
words. Baron Trump. There's one more
thing that I would like to share, Sid,
if I can, just tying it together. this
year
on on November the 11th, which is 11-11.
November the 11th in 1620, the Mayflower
dropped anchor uh at Plymouth Rock.
Well, this year 11-11,
2020 is the 400year anniversary of the
Mayflower. And the Lord said, Jeff, just
as I raised up a deliverer,
I raised up a deliverer who who
confronted the powers of the day
governmentally. Govern sound familiar? I
raised up the powers of the day. I will
lead my people in a glory revival that
will deliver them from any other
government, any other nation. I will
lead them through the power of signs and
wonders and miracles like they did with
Exodus in Exodus where the children of
Israel were in bondage 400 years. And
they came out through the power of
signs, wonders, and miracles. And
according to Psalm 105, they came out
with all of the gold, all of the silver,
and there was not one feeble among them
because of the healing angel. And uh
that's coming to America, it's coming to
Israel, it's coming to the Middle East,
it's coming to the nations. But
everything hinges on this election and
it's so so key.
Now he talks about 20 years. I hope he's
wrong.
And he's talking about Baron Trump.
Now who's that?
That's Donald's son. So he's thinking of
a succession where eventually even the
son of Donald Trump will play an
important role sometime in the next 20
years.
Now does the Bible say anything about
these things?
No.
Is this rooted anywhere in the Bible?
And he's saying it's coming to how many
nations or
all the world
including
including Israel.
Yeah. So we have a total mixture of all
of these things
based basically on a vision that goes
all the way back to Washington who was a
mason
and we have to ask ourselves can we run
with this.
He mentioned in this last part that
God said to him I will raise up
a savior.
The new age is also waiting for a dawn
of the new age.
Yes.
That will also have
and they're all waiting for a messiah.
Messiah.
All of this is
starting to interconnect. So basically
what we are saying is all of these
confusions that are out there in the
world can be avoided if you take a
simple thus says the word and thus says
the Lord.
And you know what making sorry for but
what makes it more confusing is the true
return of Jesus is also then imminent.
Absolutely.
So you've got all of this. The devil is
not stupid.
No, he's not stupid.
He knows that all of this is culminating
at the same time.
Absolutely. And how many nations does he
want to have deceived?
Everybody.
All of them.
So, some of them accept Jesus Christ as
their as their personal savior. Some of
them don't. Some of them outright reject
him even as of any significance
whatsoever. And as we said right in the
beginning, that is the key.
That is the key. So now I can have a
union and I can have peace and I have
prosperity and I can have a kingdom with
people that accept Jesus, with people
that don't accept Jesus, with people
that outright decry him as an impostor.
That is a Babylonian confusion if ever
there was one.
And it's also interesting how they use
dates and jubilees and all of these
things like uh the Mayflower and the
date that he used for the Mayflower.
Yes.
And November
11 November 1120
and the Mayflower was then and then
1111. It will be exactly 400 years since
that time and that a deliverer would
come and the children of Israel were
exactly 400 years and then they were
delivered and so he is implying that
Donald Trump will be the deliverer.
Can you use uh prophecy in that way? Is
that a biblical way of interpreting
prophecy?
Nope. Not at all.
No. So,
uh, we're not trying to be harsh here.
We're just trying to show people that
your criteria always has to be the word
of God.
Let's let's put a Jewish voice into the
mix. Now, here we have another prophet
or prophecy,
and this is Messianic Judaism. Let's
hear what they have to say.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, the harbinger began
when I was standing at ground zero and I
saw this the tree and this and and and I
and I was led that something said you
have to tr you have to check this out.
It became this mystery. The harbinger
for those who don't know um is the
mystery of the template of warning and
judgment of a nation that has known God
and has turned away from ancient Israel.
And in its last days of ancient Israel,
these nine harbingers or signs appear in
the land. And we've spoken, you were one
of the first people I ever spoke to, you
know, in the media, um, and how every
sign precisely, eerily, you know, um,
involving uh, starting with 9/11 that it
always begins with this strike on the
land and it's a warning strike. It's a
shaking of the nation. Um, but then
comes this period of time after that and
uh, this window of time and if you go
following the template, the nation is
given this time period. Um, and if to
come back to God, if it doesn't come
back, then greater shakings come. And
the thing is, I I've sensed that we were
coming to the end of this window or at
least the end of a part of this window
um before 2020. I I sense that 2020 was
going to be I mean, I told people about
it. 2020 was going to be this this time
where where we're in danger of the with
the window. And I actually and I told
people about Beth Israel at the
beginning of the year, I believe it's a
year of shaking. And the thing is when I
looked back at the harbinger, Jonathan,
when I read things to come, there's a
chapter called things to come and it
talks about the greater the shakings
that will resume in the nation. And I'm
just going to adjust this. I just
quickly xeroxed it here. Um it says the
shakings will take the form of either
can they may take the form of economic
disintegration. Um we're seeing military
defeat, not yet. Disorder and division,
we're seeing it. the collapse of
infrastructure ma we're seeing it
man-made calamities calamities of nature
and goes on and the thing is that there
that's the pattern the pattern is the sh
you have that initial warning strike
then you have a time period and then you
have the greater shakings um not only
that but in that when I looked at the
chapter Jonathan it it speaks about it
when it speaks about the shaking to come
it speaks about the word crown the word
crown is the word corona now I I didn't
know it's there but it's there in things
to come and the other thing is I won't
get into it now but it actually when I
looked at it it actually pinpoints the
year 2020 and I'll I'll tell I'll show
you but it's there in the harbinger you
can read you can read it not that God
had not that it had to happen but that
it's happening and that's one of the
templates biblical templates why for
years I was looking at this year 2020
and so now we are dealing with great
shakings
so now we have the crown we have the
corona we have everything mixed in there
And uh he's talking about all of these
world events.
Yeah. He even mentioned calamities,
man-made and natural
exactly
change.
Now again, let's let's just go back to
square one, the heart of the end time
events that will take place. We find in
the heart of the book of Revelation
and that is from chapter 11 all the way
through to chapter 17. And then we get
esquetolo es esquetology coming in.
And the role players to watch are the
beast out of the sea
and the beast out of the earth.
And the one the beast out of the sea is
the is the papacy because that was
clearly defined by the reformers
and they were all of one accord when it
came to that issue. And the beast out of
the earth is the United States of
America which will once again
introduce an image to the beast and
enforce papal decrees. In other words,
what the Bible is saying is that the
system of the first beast Rome which was
church and state together,
yes,
will be replaced by the second beast
that will do its bidding. But before it
can do that, it must first create an
image. In other words, it must become
like the first one was. So the king of
the north, which is the first one, must
defeat the secularism and go back to the
status quo. That's what we have to
watch. Do these prophets in any sense
ever warn against the first peace?
No.
There's no warning against warning
against the first whatsoever. Roman
Catholicism. No.
Okay. Is there any warning about the
image of the beast?
No.
No. Nothing. So, is there something
missing?
Yes.
So, everything that's happening around
is being attacked. And the problem is
the separation of church and state.
And it's fascinating to me and we've
we've we've shown it in previous
discussions
that even the Jews are saying that the
church and the state in America must
come together. even though the they're
talking about the Christian world coming
together. That's what we need for
morality. So the entire heart of the
book of revelation is left out of the
scenario.
Now besides these prophecies, the
harbaging is of course also an
interesting word. It's a harbager is
someone who brings the news, right? Or
something that uh tells what's going to
happen in the future.
And then you have these strange
prophecies in between, very specific
ones about who's going to die and what's
going to happen. And everybody is on a
roller coaster with all of these
prophecies.
Is there any thus says the Lord in all
of this? So listen to this one. I found
this one rather interesting.
We are in a very sad state, ladies and
gentlemen. A very sad state. And God is
going to deal with all these false
apostles and all all these false
prophets and prophetesses. Interesting.
These people call themselves prophets,
but yet when we sit down and we talk
about the word of God, hey, they have no
knowledge of the word of God. Well, I
pray six hours a day. God's not
interested in your prayers, ladies and
gentlemen. He's interested in your and
he's spending time in his word and
abiding in his word.
God doesn't care about you praying. God
is worried and wants you to be abiding
in the word.
Allow me to explain to you the events
that are going to take place. President
Trump is going to die. California is
going to have their 10.0 earthquake
before the end of summer of this year. I
went last se last September on September
4th, I released a video that California
was going to have the 10.0 earthquake
and it didn't happen. And it didn't
happen because God is warning people. It
was a warning, ladies and gentlemen. And
the sad part about it is we have not
taken heed to the warning of God.
And when the 10.0 earthquake happens, we
will lose the internet. That's why you
want to save things on your computer
and America's going to collapse. There's
something you need to look for. There's
something you need to see so that you
know that what I am telling you is about
to take place. And the event is this.
There is going to be a cataclysmic event
that's going to shock and rock the
Christian community in the next 10 to
seven days. Seven to 10 days. And that's
when the four televangelists die on the
same day. Kenneth Copeland, Jim Baker,
John Shy, and Joyce Meyers. When those
four people die on the same day, ladies
and gentlemen, then you know it's time
for you to prepare.
Yesterday morning, the Lord gave me, and
I've only had a few of them,
but I had a crystal clear vision of four
men plotting the assassination
of the president of the United States,
Donald Trump. Four men plotting his
assassination.
The death of Donald Trump is going to
mean great changes for America. But
before he dies, there's going to be one
event that's going to take place. And
that is that event is and I've done
videos on this before is there's going
to be four televangelists
Kenneth Copelan, Jim Baker, John Shy,
Joyce Meyers that are all going to die
on the same day. The biblical foundation
is 1st Samuel chapter 4. You will see
that Eli, his two sons, and his
daughter-in-law all died on the same
day. When that happens, you know that
the death of Donald J. Trump is soon
behind, not far after.
He predicted an earthquake and it never
happened.
Yeah.
So it didn't happen because God was
still giving a warning.
Now it's possible God said Nineveh is
going to fall and it didn't because they
repented, right? But was there any
repentance in California that you know
about?
No. So what does the Bible say when
somebody says something and it doesn't
happen?
He's a false prophet. And then four tele
evangelists are going to die on the same
day and then Donald Trump will be
assassinated. But apparently they say
there have been many attempts on Donald
Trump's life.
But be that as it may, this is just
throwing more information into the world
and people are looking to this one and
he's very adamant. God gave him this
vision, right?
He's saying he's saying that the others
are false prophets. The others are false
prophets and so they're going to
disappear. Is it possible to take names
out of the Bible, let's say Eli and his
sons, and say, "Let's apply that to four
televangelists living today."
It's possible to do it, but the accuracy
of it,
especially if one of them is a woman,
right?
You're cherry-picking to
Yeah, it's cherry picking. Absolutely.
context for you.
So can we bottom line can we in any way
put our faith in signs and wonders in
prophecies in all of these things? Can
we do that?
If it is
um aligned with the Bible and like to
the law and to the testimony then you
can but you must filter and test it.
Exactly.
And then you only can start relying on
it. Now, we've been speaking a lot about
signs of the times
and uh you know, some people will say
conspiracy, but as long as it is aligned
with the Bible and with the word of God,
then it's not a conspiracy.
Yeah. I think in in the past,
this is episode 30. I think in the past
29 episodes, that's one of the main
things we've been trying to put keep to
bring over.
Yes. If it's you, your filter is the
Bible. Even if we use Ellen White's
writings, you filter it through the
Bible.
It has to be in harmony with the Bible.
And there that's why all these prophets,
you you put them on the same.
So what is our message to the people out
there? And what is our message to the
people within the church? Because the
danger as we saw is that even the elect
will be deceived
and that miracles and signs and wonders
will bring this about
and especially miracles of healing.
Yes.
Well, that's very hard to just ignore.
Right.
Finally,
our discussion would not be complete if
we didn't also refer to Lou Engel, who
of course was the man who organized the
call and the send and is very very
prominent in the evangelical circles.
So, let us see what he has to say and
put that into the mix.
Recently, when President Trump was
elected, WHO IS THE MOST PROLIFE
president in the history of America, his
stand for the church has been so
amazing. I I felt like the Lord rebuked
me and and said to me, Lou, you've told
the story of Wilbur Force in the movie
theater. You told YOUR STORY OF YOUR
PRAYER, but you didn't believe. YOU JUST
THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT STORY, but I'm
answering your story. If the church will
pray, I'm answering your story.
that President Trump is the Wilbur force
you prayed for at that moment. And so I
bring it to this thing where recently
recently I've been praying. I've done
40-day fasts over the years. And I said,
"Lord, I can't call another 40-day fast.
It's a crisis, but I can't do it. I've
called too many fasts." And I said,
"Lord, if you want me to call this fast,
then God, you've got to confirm it to me
because I don't want to have good
ideas." Two nights later, I have a
dream. And in the dream, I'm in an
intimate conversation with President
Trump. And I could feel his pain. I
could feel his loneliness. I could feel
the pressure and the attack against his
life in the dream. And suddenly I say,
and I lift my voice with deep emotion
toward him and deep love. And I said, I
am going to pour out my heart for 40
days of fasting. And uh and I'm going to
be praying for you and for America. I
woke up and I knew that that was the
call. We're calling it the hinge of
history fast. And I would like to invite
many of you that are watching to enter
into this fast that started two days ago
DARING TO BELIEVE THAT PRINCIPALITIES OF
POWERS of death and racism, anger, and
riots can be broken in the heavens with
massive fasting and prayer. We're doing
this. And I think it's sovereign that
I'm on the phone with you, Allan, and
with all these constituents. It's a time
I'm afraid that we're at a moment that
if things don't shift, we could be
headed to a civil war.
So he is saying that everything has to
come together and we need a willow
force. We need a willow force. Now
that's very interesting to me because I
was an evolutionist right before I
discovered the truth of the scriptures.
Now, Bishop Wilburforce was the one who
debated uh in the issue of of Darvinism
and uh he debated Darin's bulldog Huxley
and apparently in that debate even
though Wilbur Force was very fiery uh
Huxley was the one who actually won the
day so the scientific world has to say
it today. So basically what he's saying
is that Donald Trump is the one that
opposes secularism
and opposes the anti-God movement just
like Wilberforce opposed Darvinism
and they're all rooting for Trump.
Now if Trump wins that will be
interesting
because what kind of religion and state
union will you have then? It's going to
be an interesting one with if you look
at all the advisor and all the different
um denominations that is it going to be
a biblical union or is it going to be a
papal union?
It's going to be papal.
It's going to be a papal union
ecumenical one.
So we've seen many visions. We've seen
uh we've discussed them whether they are
in harmony with the Bible. Let's just
end on this quote which comes from
Maranata
and it talks about satanic miracles and
it quotes Revelation 13:13
which is the heart of what we have
discussed where we have the two beasts
in this wonderful revelation and he
doeth great wonders so that he makes
fire come down from heaven on the earth
in the sight of men as the people of God
approach the perils of the last days.
Satan holds earnest consultation with
his angels as to the most successful
plan of overthrowing their faith. He
sees that the popular churches are
already lulled to sleep by his deceptive
power.
Did we see that?
Yes.
What's the criterion? The word of God.
By pleasing sophistry and lying wonders,
he can continue to hold them under his
control. Therefore, he directs his
angels to lay their snares, especially
for those who are looking for the second
advent of Christ and endeavoring to keep
the commandments of God.
Even the elect will be deceived if they
focus on these things.
We are warned that in the last days he
will work with signs and lying wonders
and he will continue these wonders until
the close of probation that he may point
to them as evidence that he is an angel
of light and not of darkness. This is
serious.
Yes.
Satan will come in to deceive if
possible the very elect. He claims to be
Christ and he's coming in pretending to
be a great medical missionary.
They're waiting for the Messiah, right?
He will cause fire to come down from
heaven in the sight of men to prove that
he is God.
The bottom line of what we have been
discussing
is that the Bible is the criterion from
which we work. As we stated in the
beginning, the centrality of Christ is
absolute paramount.
We cannot mix various religious systems
and still have Christ in the centrality.
So my prayer is that God's people will
take a firm stand on a thus says the
Lord
and that people out there that are
confused and that have left the light
that has been shining upon the path. I
mean the reformation gave such clear
light.
Why is that being rejected?
Why are there only flashes here and
flashes there? But they get lost in the
noise. We need to get back to the clear
light that God gave to the founders of
the reformation movement and to the
final remnant that keep the commandments
of God and hold to the testimony of
Jesus. In the upcoming episode, we can
then discuss what will be the final uh
events
around
around these uh false things and what is
coming upon
God's people and the earth.
Yes.
And then we can carry on from there to
deliverance of God's people.
Yes, we will discuss that. We will
discuss
what these final events will be and why
the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus is so prominent a feature of the
final message to humanity. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, the issue of signs and
wonders and of prophecies
that pervade the world out there is a
serious problem.
But not only out there, Lord, within our
very own ranks, we have similar
experiences. Every wind of doctrine is
blowing. Help us, Lord, to be rooted in
the truth, to stand by the pillars of
the faith which are founded on an
unshakable foundation.
Give us strength and wisdom for the
times in which we are living is our
prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Thank you for watching this video. To
subscribe, click here. When the bell
appears, click again to get
notifications.
To watch the next video, click here.
Thank you.